Hi everybody. Thanks. I'm
pretty sure you can hear me.
The sound guys are working
on it, so that's great. Um,
thanks for having me here today.
I want to start by just
asking what seems to be a, uh,
a simple question and that
is what underlies success.
What allows us to succeed academically
and professionally to have financial
security, to eat right exercise and be
healthy, to have good relationships.
What's the key? Well, it's not very
often that you can find a magic bullet,
but in this case you can self control
the ability to delay gratification,
to value the future.
More than the present is what matters.
And there's lots of research
that attest to this,
but in one way or another it kind of
all derives from what is arguably one of
the most famous experiments in 20th
century psychology. And that is Walter.
Michelle is the marshmallow test and
most of you probably know what this is,
but in case you don't,
let me tell you quickly.
So Michelle would take four year olds
and he would put a marshmallow down in
front of me and say,
you can eat this now.
But if you wait until I come back 15
minutes from now, you can have two.
And now this is a child friendly
version of a dilemma that we all face,
something that economists
call intertemporal choice,
which is basically decisions that have
different consequences as time unfolds.
And I like to kind of explain this with
a reference to Aesop's fable of the ant
and the grasshopper. Um, if you remember
the story, it was a beautiful summer.
The grasshopper spent its time dancing
and frolicking while the ant went to the
fields and toiled to put away food
for the winter. When the winter came,
the aunt had a lot of food. The
grasshopper was out of luck and starved.
And so what you're seeing is
we're, we're contrasting here, um,
desire for pleasure in the moment
versus a willingness to sacrifice in the
moment for larger pleasures
and gains downline.
Now the problem for us humans is we tend
to discount the value of the future.
In some ways,
this makes good sense of burden.
The hand can certainly be worth
more than two in the Bush sometimes,
but we tend to do it. I'm a bit
excessively, right? We do it so much,
especially as our world has become a
more certain place that we tend to make
very seemingly irrational decisions.
Now what Michelle found is that the
kids who had self can show we're able to
stop and not gobble the marshmallow
bit weight over time had much better
outcomes, better grades, higher sats,
better relationships. Since that time,
lots of people have tied the ability to
delay gratification and to persevere in
the face of challenges,
to having better savings for retirement,
less credit card debt, lower
obesity, less addictive behaviors,
less impulsivity and
shopping and consumerism.
And so that raises an important
question for us, right?
If self control is so important,
how are we supposed to obtain it?
How we get more of it now here?
Um,
Michelle's view is still kind of the
one that's held commonly both by,
by the lay public and scientists alike.
And it's that emotions are the
being of self control, right?
These emotions have to be overruled
by kind of cool cognitive,
well planned, um, thoughts and
willpower for going to succeed.
And if you go to your local
Barnes and noble or Amazon,
you will find the shelves filled with
bestsellers that extol just this idea.
So all of these books
in one way or another,
urge people to use willpower or other
cognitive strategies involving executive
function,
which is that part of your mind that
allows you to kind of plan a and reason
yourself,
uh,
and to developing certain habits and
ways of dealing with temptations.
But you know,
an idea has really entered the Zeitgeists,
not when you see it in Barnes and noble,
but when you see it on sesame street.
And so in 2013,
the folks there who are very dedicated
to child education realize that teaching
kids self control and grit was an
important part of them being successful.
And so they thought,
who better to teach this?
Then the walking talking it himself,
cookie monster. Right? And so in 2013,
cookie's still said, me want cookie, but
they added something and now he said,
but me,
wait.
And so for that whole season we saw
cookie teach kids how to use willpower to
avoid their temptations and he
would distract himself. Yeah.
By creating strategies like
pretending the thing he wanted.
My favorite was the cookie was stinky
fish or he would develop all kinds of
strategies cause he knew his willpower
would probably fail. But unlike cookie,
what happens, for most
of us, he was successful.
What happens for most of us is we're
not as often as we'd like and what the
scientific research shows
is that willpower can work,
but it tends to be rather fragile.
Um,
Kathleen vose who's at the University
of Minnesota and kind of one of the
world's leading experts on self
control, um, followed people,
um, four weeks in their daily lives,
um, with like, you know, beepers and,
but I sound old beepers, smartphones, um,
where they could actually
see what, what, what, um,
temptations people were facing
and how they dealt with it.
And what she found is that one out of
more than one out of every six times
people tried to resist the temptation
and stick to their goals. You know,
to go to the gym or not overeat or not
overspend or work hard rather than watch
TV and they failed.
And for goals that are even more
important to us, the stats are even worse.
So 8% of New Year's resolutions or capital
years end 25% fail right now in the
second week of January.
Okay.
And so you're not alone if you're
one of these. And so you know,
my question as a scientist is if we'd
been using science for the past 20 years
to try and help people develop
self control, develop grit,
which is the ability to kind of persevere
in the face of challenges to achieve
your long term goals, then why are we
still so bad? Why is Angela Duckworth,
he's one of the um, discovers and
major proponents of grid is set. Is it?
Why is it that no one really knows how
to cultivate self control and grit in a
way that endures?
And I think it's because when we faced
a fork in the road beside between
deciding to use strategies based on
reason and willpower and one's based on
emotion, we chose the wrong
one. And because we did that,
we've kind of set ourselves up for a
lot of failure and a lot of frustration.
Let me tell you why.
Think that one thing we know about
willpower is it tends to be difficult to
maintain,
not because it's some finite resource,
but because every time you're trying to
resist the temptation to do something
fun, your brain interprets that as effort
cause it's discounting the value of the
future goal and over time as it keeps
becoming harder and harder to do something
and harder to maintain your focus,
it feels more effortful.
And so what we know is that when
you're trying to resist temptations
continuously,
over time you're going to fail.
And the more often you try it,
the more likely you will fail
without some type of, of,
of respite in between. Um, you may say,
well but I know people who have
good self control and willpower
here with the research shows is there are
self control isn't any better than the
rest of us. The people who we think have
really good self control and willpower,
the reason they succeed is because they
structure their lives so as not to come
in contact with temptation
in the first place.
It's actually as if they know
that willpower is going to fail.
And so they're smart enough to structure
their life so that they can avoid that
temptation appear like they're
in good control of their desires,
but perhaps potentially
worse than willpower.
Being weak is that reason itself.
And how we set our goals and decide what
we're going to do is an objective but
can actually be really biased.
So let me give you an example
of what I mean by this.
One thing we study in my lab is cheating.
And so a typical experiment we do is we'll
bring people in and we say, okay, look,
there are two tasks that need to be done.
Uh,
a short and fun one involving
photo hunt takes about 10 minutes,
a really long, onerous someone. Um,
it takes about 45 minutes doing logic
problems and things that most of our
students don't like to do. Here's a
virtual coin flipper. Why is it virtual?
So I can control what comes
up on it. Um, if it's heads,
you're going to do the short
fund photo hunt. If it's towels,
you're going to do this long
owner's problem and that
guy was sitting out in the
hall next to you, he's going to get
stuck doing whatever one you don't do.
And then we leave them alone and they're
on hidden video, which they don't know.
Of course. Um, what do you think they do?
They cheat.
What percentage of
people cheat? Um, close.
90%. 90% of people cheat
and bite. She, I mean,
they either don't use the virtual flipper,
just say, you know, go to and say,
I got, yeah, I flipped it
and I got the easy task.
Or they flip it once it comes up with
the answer they don't want and they pick
yet to try and see what
they're going to get.
Now the interesting thing
here is if you ask people,
if you're in this situation and
you didn't flip, is that wrong?
The only time in my life
I get unanimous data,
100% of people say to not flip the coin,
to cheat on this task would be wrong.
Yet 90% of them do. Now I'm not
running this outside of the prison.
So the question is,
why is it the case that most people just
like you and me kind of given to our
temptations here?
Well,
at the end of the experiment we asked
them how fairly did you act these 90% you
cheated and this is a scale of one to
seven to the higher numbers basically mean
you, you reacted more fairly.
And people say, Oh, you know,
they're above the mid
point. I'm like, I did okay.
If you then run the experiment again,
except this time people are
watching someone else cheat, right?
Suddenly it's not as fair.
Right? So if you do it, it's bad.
If I do this exact same thing, it's more
fair. Okay. And then this is hypocrisy.
Plain and simple. Now when I
talk about some people say, oh,
well you know what happened? It's like
there are emotions got the best of them.
Um,
their willpower wasn't strong enough to
override their desire to not want to do
this awful task.
That's not what it was.
The reason we know is when we
ran the experiment of third time,
we put people under what's
called a cognitive load,
which is a way to kind of occupy their
ability to kind of engage in reason and
rationalization.
Basically,
we're distracting them with a secondary
task while they're deciding what they're
doing here. When you asked them how fairly
did you act? Hypocrisy goes away. Okay.
They realize that what they did,
they're cheating was bad and
just as bad as anybody else's.
They don't give themselves leniency.
And so what was leading to this
was rationalization, right?
Everybody has this
immediate Pang of guilt.
But if we give you a minute to think
about what you did or what you want to do,
your construct a story for why it
was okay for you to do this right?
And people will say, Oh, well normally
I wouldn't have done this, but you know,
I had a, I had an appointment,
I couldn't be late for a,
or my favorite was the guy who said,
well I wouldn't have
done it except you know,
the guy was sitting out in the
hall is going to get the next tech.
He looked like he was an engineering
major and I thought he would really like
the harder problems.
Right.
And so you see what people
are doing is they're there,
they're rationalizing themselves into
doing something that goes against their
own moral code.
What's the problem here?
It means that many times when
we're trying to resist a goal to,
you know,
watch TV instead of go to the gym to
not work hard to throw in the talent.
Something we can talk ourselves into.
Why that's good.
We'll often reason ourselves into
why it's okay for us to do this.
Why it's okay for me to buy the new iPhone
instead of put money into retirement
because I deserve it.
And if we can reason ourselves into this,
then we're never going to use
willpower in the first place. Finally,
the last reason I think reasonable power,
the wrong way to go about trying to foster
our goals and our longterm success is
there actually can be detrimental.
So when those of you who
have like struggled with
trying to achieve a goal and
trying to use willpower to get it, you
can feel this tension that you often have.
So this is work done by Greg Miller,
who's a psychologist at
Northwestern university.
And what he found is he
looked at kids who were from,
from disadvantaged backgrounds
and who had self control.
And we're trying to resist temptations,
right? To have to have grit and succeed.
And what he found is that,
yeah,
those who had higher self control
based on willpower and trying to force
themselves to do these things did succeed
more, but it came at a cost. Right?
These kids also showed premature aging
of their immune cells because of the
stress involved.
And so yeah,
they're succeeding but they're not
going to be around as long to enjoy it.
And it's because we're trying to always
fight a desire is putting your body
under an intense amount of stress.
And so what I want to convince you of
today is that emotions aren't the problem.
Emotions don't always lead to
inpatients. Sure. There are some,
there are things like anger that one
that will lead you to strike out.
There are things like, um, um,
lust and desire that may may make
you act for immediate gratification,
but there are other emotions
that do different things. Okay.
Things like gratitude, compassion,
and an authentic feeling of pride.
Not Arrogance or Hubris. I mean,
if you think about it, why these,
these are the emotions that
underlie social living.
These are the emotions that
make us willing to invest
in other people that cost
to themselves to do ourselves.
When I feel grateful,
I'm willing to pay somebody back
and spend a lot of time to do that.
If I feel compassion for somebody, I
am willing to give them time, money,
a shoulder to cry on something that that
is maybe difficult for me in the moment,
but we'll help them.
If I feel proud of my abilities,
I'm willing to work hard to develop them,
to help my team and myself
succeed as part of it.
Sorry. Um, and so if I'm right,
then what it means is that if
you're feeling these emotions,
it should make it easier for you
to succeed in the marshmallow test.
But I don't work with kids.
I work with adults and most
adults don't like marshmallows,
but they do like cold,
hard cash.
And so we ran the experiment that's an
adult version of the marshmallow tests in
this way. We brought people
in and we gave them a whit.
First we asked them to describe
a time they felt very grateful,
they felt very happy or they're just,
you know,
something about their daily
life that was kind of neutral.
We that had them complete a bunch
of questions that were of the form,
you can have x dollars now or y dollars
and z days were why was always greater
than x and z varied over weeks to months.
So it's kind of like what you want one
marshmallow now or two marshmallows in
three days.
Except the typical question was would
you rather have $35 now or $75 in three
weeks?
And to make it interesting for people,
we told them we'd pick one of their
many responses and we'd honor it.
So if you said you wanted a $35,
now we'd hand you $35 if you said
like 65 or 75 and three weeks,
we'd mail you the check.
Now from this we could count and determine
how much people devalue or discount
the value of the future. And what
you're seeing here is a things graft as,
as annual discount factors in one
way to understand what that means is,
uh,
an annual discount factor of 0.15 means
people think that $100 in a year is
worth $15 today. Or another way of
saying that is if I gave you $15 today,
you forego getting $100 in a year,
which I dunno about you,
but unless you need that $15 to survive,
you know,
the ability to kind of Quinn couple of
your money in a year's time given with
the banks are paying, it's
pretty good. Um, but people
were pretty impatient, right?
People who are feeling nothing
in particular, uh, had a
discount factor of 0.17,
right? They'd say, I see seven,
I see $100 in years where $17 now
give me $17 now you can forget them.
Forget about that.
$100 a year.
What about people who were
feeling grateful right here?
We doubled their level of self control.
These people discounted the value
of the future less for them.
$100 a year from now was were $30,
which meant if I gave them
the same deal as most people,
would you take $17 to forego it?
They wouldn't take it now just to show
you that it's not just about feeling good,
happy people. We're no
different than people who were
feeling, uh, neutral, right?
There's something intrinsically
motivating about valuing the future,
willing to sacrifice about these
social emotions that bind us together,
like gratitude. And we followed,
we ran the experiment again,
but we followed people for three
weeks in their daily life, um,
and measuring every day how
much gratitude they felt.
And what we found is you can see here
the people who felt the mean level of
gratitude and one standard
deviation above and below.
And what you see is a nice
linear function. The more
gratitude you feel in life,
the more patient you are.
At the end of those three weeks,
we gave them a similar
financial task to do.
So experiencing these emotions are kind
of like booster shots of self control.
They make you more patient,
they make you value the future more.
They make you willing to wait for the
bigger cash, the bigger marshmallow,
to not eat the Broccoli so that,
I mean to eat the Broccoli so that you
can be healthy instead of the French
fries when you see your doctor
next. Um, how about pride?
Well, if I'm right, then pride should
also increase the value of the future.
But we want it to look at this in term of,
uh,
in terms of a measure that people
typically look at in terms of grit,
which is perseverance,
right?
We'll pride make people persevere
more on tasks that are difficult.
Now I know what you're thinking.
Probably Pride, gratitude, compassion.
I kind of get where does pride fit in
by pride, I'm not meaning in arrogant,
humoristic sense of pride thinking you
have skills that you don't have it.
I'm not trying to be political,
he's just the biggest example right now.
But there are,
there are certainly Democrats who
fit this bill as much as Republicans.
But what I mean by pride
is actually having,
having pride in skills that you have
worked hard to develop and others
recognizing you for,
for working hard to develop.
So we ran an experiment where we brought
people in and um, we had them, uh,
do this task on what we
called visual spacial ability.
It's kind of like mental
rotation and these things.
And then we gave them feedback,
sorry, in, in, in the first condition.
We didn't give them any feedback.
And then we gave them a second task,
which you said is related to
your visual spatial ability.
It's really hard and difficult.
Please work on it as long as
you can in a second condition.
We gave them feedback on how
they did on the first test,
the first visual spacial test,
we said, oh, you did very well.
You scored in the 94th percentile.
We showed them what that meant, um,
and then let them do another task.
But in the third condition,
we not only let them know they did well,
but we made them feel proud of
this ability because let's face it,
most people don't really care
about their visual spacial ability.
And so we wanted to make them feel
proud. And so we told them is, look,
this is really important skill. I mean
this, you know, you've done really well.
The experimenter gave them kind of a pat
on the back end kind of nonverbals that
this is really good.
We then compared how long
they worked on these tasks.
And what you found is there
were no difference between
the folks who didn't get
any feedback and people who told who
were told that they did okay on the task.
But the people who are made to feel proud,
persevered for 40% longer
on that next difficult task.
Why?
Because the pride pushes them to value
the goal of getting better at something
that those around you or
you yourself value, right?
It gave them the grit to keep going,
to keep studying, to keep working,
to keep exercising,
whatever it may be.
Compassion works similarly. Um, you know,
when I was researching this book on,
on self control,
I thought I need to go
straight to the top.
Who knows more about self control than
Buddhist monks? Probably not anybody,
right? A lot of Buddhism is about,
about detachment from desire.
And so a friend of mine is a
high ranking, um, Buddhist Lama.
And he told me that when monks first
take their vows to be chaste and to not
gamble and to not drink,
they fell a lot just like the rest of us
because they're relying on willpower to
do it. But over time, through meditation,
it begins to unleash this
feeling of compassion in them.
And when they feel compassion,
suddenly it becomes very easily,
suddenly the temptations
fall away. Now, if you
read the New York Times or the Atlantic,
you're going to hear that, uh, you know,
meditation has all these great things
for you. It lowers your blood pressure,
it increases your creativity,
um, increases your memory.
All those are true. That's not
why it was created, right? Um,
it was created basically to help end
suffering both for yourself and for other
people to make people more altruistic.
And so to show you that it actually can
evoke compassion and make people willing
to engage in self control.
We wanted to run an experiment.
We brought people in for eight weeks,
um,
39 people from the Boston area and they
were going to take part in a meditation
experiment and um,
they were either you're put on a wait
list so they didn't meditate or they came
in once a week to train,
uh,
and be treated by a Buddhist Lama and
were given mp3s to take home and practice.
The end of those three weeks,
we had them come to our lab.
We told them we're going to have,
um,
do memory tests on you. That really
wasn't true. Um, when they came in,
the true experiment happened in
the labs waiting room, right?
So there were three chairs in the labs
waiting room to more occupied by actors,
people who worked for us.
And so the subject would come in
and they would of course sit down.
The third share, a few
minutes later, another actor,
actress actually came in
and, um, she was on crutches.
She had her foot and one of those ankle
boots you wear when your foot is broken.
She's coming down the hall and she's
wincing in pain. She walks into the room.
The two people who are there in the chair,
I was already ignore her. We told them,
you know, thumb your cell phones,
just, you know, don't pay any mind.
The question then was what
would the subject actually do?
Now this is a situation where it's known
to make it very hard to help as we call
bystanders situation. And
you see it unfortunately on
the streets a lot. You know,
I mean there,
there are people who there could be a
homeless individual who looks like they're
in need.
Everybody's just walking by.
And that makes it easier for
everybody else to just walk by.
Because if nobody's helping this person,
why should I?
And so we set up a similar situation.
What would the person who was
meditating for eight weeks or not do?
And so what we find is a
pretty large effect. So a,
among those who didn't meditate,
right,
three out of 19 decided
that they would get up,
sacrifice their own comfort to give
this chair to relieve somebody else's
discomfort.
We boosted that to 50% after
eight weeks of meditation.
Now this is a small sample.
So we wanted to run it again.
We also were interested in scalability.
Right? And the problem with this is yeah,
meditation can work this way,
but lots of people don't have access to
a Buddhist Lama or the time or money to
do this. Uh, and so we
partnered with, um, headspace,
which was an app for your smartphone.
And the reason we used headspace,
Andy Puddicombe actually has a lot
of monastic training. And so we,
we figured he knew what he was doing.
So around the experiment, again,
we had 56 people. Uh, we
had them for three weeks,
do either headspace or Lumosity. It was
billed as a cognitive training course. Um,
and then we had them do the same
experiment in the lab and we found,
uh, a similar effect that is, uh,
people in the control condition.
Four out of 29,
we're willing to get up and help
this other person versus, um,
10 out of 27.
So again,
a fairly large boost in the people
who are willing to sacrifice their own
comfort to help somebody else. How
does that relate to self control? Well,
we wanted to look at self
control in a different domain.
And that is the domain of aggression,
right?
And sometimes you get angry at people,
um, you want to lash out at them.
And that may not be a good strategy for
a number of reasons and it takes self
control to not do that.
So we brought 46 people into the study.
We had them again, do headspace, half
of them do headspace for three weeks.
Um, and then I'm going to skip talking
about this strip. Part of the experiment.
We had them do this experiment where
they thought they were going to prepare
speeches for each other.
So you would prepare a speech,
then you would deliver it to
somebody else via video. Of course,
the other person was actually
an actor who worked for us.
And so you would write your little speech
about your life goals and you'd give
it to this person. And that person's
job was to give you feedback.
And basically that person, um, would
say basically, this is terrible.
You know, I can't believe these are your
goals. What do you, what are you doing?
Right? And so this was, uh,
this was a strategy of paradigm developed
by Tom Tom Denson and he's shown that
it reliably evokes anger and frustration
and people both in what they say and in
terms of their blood pressure and their
heart rate and lots of other things.
And so after we did
this, we told them, okay,
now we're moving to a
taste perception study.
We want you to prepare taste samples for
each other and we're going to measure
your, uh, taste acuity. Um,
today we're doing hot sauce samples and
so we give them this evil bottle of hot
sauce, like was labeled really
hot. And we told them, okay,
you have to prepare the sample for each
other and the amount that you put in the
couple we placed in its entirety
in the person's mouth. Now again,
this wasn't developed by
us. This is another strategy
that you use in the lab to,
to understand aggression.
The person doesn't actually drink it,
but it's actually a way of,
people know this is going to cause pain.
They can control how much
they're going to do. A,
and you can get a measure of that
without actually causing any pain.
So what do we see?
So people who didn't meditate,
they were kind of angry and they poured
seven grams of hot sauce into this cup.
Now when they're not angry, so we've done
this experiment. People aren't angry.
The average amount people pouring in is
about one to two grounds because they
know they've got to put something in
there for the taste. Sample sevens. Hello?
[inaudible] what happened to the
people who, who meditated? Okay.
They had a lot more self control. They
poured a lot less. Yes, they were angry,
they said were angry,
but they were more able to control
their impulses to lash out.
And ultimately this is another way of
valuing the future because what happens
when you lash out is you tend to engage
in tit for tat escalations of vials.
So that's just to show you that,
you know,
meditation is one way to
kind of boost these emotions.
Compassion beyond that has been showed
people the more often people feel
compassion,
both for others and themselves has been
tied to better performance on the job.
And in school more exercise,
healthier, eating, lower consumerism,
less tobacco and alcohol use.
Again,
we're seeing the more often you experience
these emotions leading to greater
self control.
Now the benefit of using emotional
strategies is they don't work from the top
down. We're not always reminding ourselves
or resist this goal. I mean, sorry,
resist this temptation so you can
achieve your goal. They're not stressful.
There's no fight.
They work from the bottom up by
making us value the future more.
They ease us into persevering toward it.
If we value our future goals more,
it's not a struggle to want to pursue
them and to be willing to accept
sacrifices to obtain them. And so yeah,
there are different ways to get there.
There are cognitive
strategies like willpower and
precommitment and Planning and
distraction,
but there are emotional strategies
and for the reasons I've told you,
I think the emotional strategies
are the stronger ones.
But there's one last benefit I want
to tell you about before I end,
and that is these,
using these pro social emotions actually
addresses another big problem of modern
life, which is the plague of
loneliness. Consider this.
In 1985 80% of Americans reported that
they had at least one friend that they
could rely on and share things
with and felt comfortable with.
By 2005 that had dropped to 57% today,
53% of Americans regularly
report that they feel lonely,
especially at work in
their professional lives.
And one thing we know
from work by John Kasey,
Opo is a psychologist at
University of Chicago,
is that loneliness is as
bad for you as smoking.
It will lower your life
expectancy to the same extent.
It is a detriment,
your psychological wellbeing,
and to your physical health because
of the stress that it causes.
Now,
when you think about how
people pursue their goals,
I think the way we tend to pursue
them is in a very kind of atomistic
individualized ways.
We're putting our nose to the grindstone.
We're just focused on what we want to do,
and we're studying hard,
we're working hard, and we're not
thinking about our social connections.
So there's a famous statistic
related, uh, to grit out there,
which says that kids who scored higher
on the Grit scale actually perform better
in high stakes things. One being here, the
uh, spelling bee, national spelling bee.
But there's a cautionary
element in there too.
If you look at the final round
of data, right? I'm sorry,
the final round.
Who won in the final round who performed
well once you can stroll for the kids?
Verbal Iq is grit didn't predict anything.
Well,
it did predict one thing and that one
thing was spending more time drilling and
studying. Okay. And what that
suggest is not that grid is bad.
Having Grit,
valuing our goals,
having a passion to pursue
them is hugely important.
And I don't mean to suggest it's not,
but there are lots of ways
that you can be gritty.
You can do it in a way that's nose to
the grindstone isolation or you can do it
by cultivating these moral emotions,
which I think will solve a problem.
Because when you cultivate these emotions,
what they tend to do is
increase your social network.
So one thing we know about people
who are high in this trait called
conscientiousness, which is um, uh,
kind of being focused on always doing
the right thing and monitoring what's
going on and being detailed oriented,
using willpower to make sure you do the
right thing. And it's like, it's almost,
it's almost perfectly
correlated with grit.
So those who are high on
conscientiousness are high end grip.
These people do fail less cause they're
working hard. But when they fell,
the hit to their wellbeing as
120% greater than the rest of us.
And the reason I think why that is is
because they don't have that social
network to capture them when they fall.
Now if you use these emotions
to build your success,
to help you persevere, you can't
help but build those bonds. Right?
We have lots of other work that
I'm not going to talk about today,
that people who experience gratitude
more often have better friendships,
higher quality, social lives,
compassion and warmth. Um,
or one of the first things that the,
that we look for and who we want to be
friends with and that our mind notices
pride, a true fried and your
skills not being an arrogant,
but taking pride in your work and
your ability is very attractive.
It makes other people want to work
with you and even see you as a leader.
So by cultivating these emotions, they
not only help you achieve your own goals,
they help you automatically build
a social network around you.
And if you think about it, it
makes a lot of sense, right?
Why did self control of all self control
didn't evolve to help you save for your
401k to exercise or to even
get a second marshmallow?
Selfcontrol evolved originally to
help us with social connection,
right? For, for Millennia,
401k is the whole 30,
whatever it might be.
They didn't exist, right?
What made human successful was
having good character, right?
Being fair, being honest, being generous,
being willing to accept some sacrifice
on your own to help other people.
Having those bonds is what ensured success
for most of our evolutionary history.
And these were the
emotions that underlied it.
So now what we can do is take these
same emotions that made us willing to in
other people and pivot their power to
make us willing to cooperate with it helps
someone else who's very important to us.
And that is our own future self.
And if you follow this route,
right,
what I like to say is it not only gives
you grit but grace, right? That is,
it helps get rid of this dichotomy that
David Brooks likes to talk about between
resume virtues and eulogy virtues.
Resume virtues are those that
you need for your career.
Eulogy ones are the ones that
you want to be remembered for.
By following this route,
you're going to maximize both.
And what that will do is ensure that
you'll have a balanced and a resilient
success. And at the end of
your life, when you look back,
you're going to have less regrets.
So thank you for coming and listening
and I'm happy to talk with you about any
questions you might have.
Sure.
Um,
did you do any studies about maybe
more negative emotions driving success,
like being vindictive or
anything like that? Ah, okay.
I thought you can say something else.
So yeah. So, so if, if people say, um,
should I be a nice guy or should I be
kind of vindictive and out for myself to
succeed? I say, well, it depends on
your timeframe. So in the short run,
being a jerk, being a cheater, being
someone who is, we'll explore it.
Other people's will quickly allow
you to recruit resources over time,
both in the workplace and in evolutionary
models that people like Martin Nowak,
um, who's a evolutionary
biologist at Harvard if run,
what we see is that individuals
who are willing to, uh,
be compassionate and trustworthy and
gratitude and to share and cooperate
honestly over time garner the most
resources. Because if you're a jerk,
yes.
In the short run you can,
you can cheat people out of stuff
and take credit for stuff in prosper.
But over time that reputation will
come back to haunt you. Um, yeah,
that was just curious what you thought I
was going to say and what, yeah, what I,
what I thought you were going to say is,
are there negative emotions that,
that are kind of moral emotions like
guilt that would actually motivate you to
behave in ways and in it's true.
So if you're guilty it will
motivate you to have self control.
If you're worried about being embarrassed,
it will motivate you to have self control.
But the problem is those are also
very stressful emotions to experience.
So guilt and shame and embarrassment
have a role to play in the social world.
They're, they're, they, they make us
behave in certain ways. It's kind of a,
a psychological kick in the pants,
but they're not something that you want
to cultivate regularly because it will
be stressful to your body to do it,
which is why I focus on
these more positive ones.
Hey there. Um, so one question I had is,
so you talked a lot about the
importance of um, uh, meditation,
which inherently is about being
present and sort of calming your mind.
And I'm thinking about
gratitude and compassion and
pride is sort of like how do,
how do you really sort of be in the moment
with where you are and appreciate it
and kind of,
you know,
half of the different sort of
emotions that go along with it.
But also fundamentally you talked a lot
about the importance of goals and being
fortunate few future looking and utilizing
the future as a means to manage how
you think about the present.
Like there's a bit of tension there in
terms of like how much should you be
utilizing the future as a reference point
and be like, I want to achieve this.
I've decided I wanted to achieve it.
I'm going to put it away for now and
focus on the moment versus keep going back
to the future as a way to kind of dictate
how you, how you live in the present.
Could you just talk about that?
Yeah, I think I'm, I'm, I'm, I've got
what you're asking if I don't correct me,
but the beauty about these
emotions, right, is they, is, they,
unlike kind of making the five year plan
and always being focused on where am I,
what am I doing is they simply give you
patients in any realm and they simply
make it willing that whenever
you're confronted with a decision,
do I want to do something
that is in line with my goals?
Whatever those goals may be,
or do I want to do something that is
fun but detrimental to those goals?
They increased the mind's value of
the future goal and thereby reduce the
tension and the fight that you're going
to engage in to try and make yourself,
um, pursue them. But the
beauty of them is, is,
is you're not always having
to think about the future.
Simply feeling these emotions
automatically recalibrates
what you're willing to
do. So as an example, when, um,
we make people feel grateful,
they're more willing to make decisions
like financial decisions that have, um,
delayed returns that benefit themselves
and everybody else. But at the same time,
they're more likely to want
to help people. They're more
likely to be willing to,
to, to make a dietary choices
that are healthy for them.
And what it does is it is,
it kind of not only calms your
desire for immediate gratification,
but makes you non-consciously
value the future.
So it's not like you're actually,
you have to stop and say, okay,
I want to work hardness.
I better be grateful this silhouette.
I can work hard on this. It kind of just
unfolds. And what do emotions do? They,
they just shape what you're going to do
next without you having to think about
it.
As,
I think cultivating these emotions allows
you to behave in ways that are more
beneficial to your future without having
to always consciously think about what
those ways are. Does that
make sense? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah.
Hi. Uh, do you have any suggestions
for exercises other than meditation?
Yeah. Yeah. So, right. So how do we do
these? So, um, for gratitude it's, it's,
it's pretty easy mean.
What we do in our experience oftentimes
is have people do gratitude journaling
or gratitude diaries.
You take five minutes a day every other
day thinking about something you're
grateful for.
The trick of course is we all have three
or four things that we're immensely
grateful for. And if you think about
the same three or four things every day,
they're going to lose their power. And
so what you have to do this, think about,
you know,
the guy who gave you directions today or
the woman who gave you her seat on the
subway or somebody who helped you out here
at your work at Google during the day.
It doesn't have to be something
that's amazingly, you're grateful for.
Even mild levels of gratitude do the same
thing. Compassion besides meditation,
one thing that we know works is
looking for links with other people.
So we do other work where we bring people
together and we just have them find
some common link.
They like the same sports team.
They liked the same music, they have a
friend in common, whatever it might be.
Just simply knowing that you have a link
with other people makes the mind more
willing to feel compassion
for that person.
And so a way to do that on a daily basis
is to stop and try and just everyday
put yourself in somebody's shoes
and feel an emotion for them.
The magic part about this is if I feel
compassion for you by trying to put
myself in your shoes and perspective
taking and think what it's like and how it
could help you,
that compassion will bleed over and it
will make me help my own future self and
other people as well.
It's like if I'm grateful because
Allen did something for me,
our work shows that it also makes me
much more likely to pay it forward and
helping the next person who is there.
I mean emotions you,
when you think about it, when you're
frightened of something, you know you're,
you're frightened and then
you hear like a scary,
you hear a creak in your house and
you're like, oh, I'm afraid of that.
Because they're setting the
expectation for what you do next.
If you're feeling gratitude or compassion,
they set the expectation for
what you're going to do next,
even if it's not related to what
you're thinking about in the moment.
Same thing for pride.
Don't take pride only an ultimately
reaching your goal because that's a long
time away. Take pride in kind of
each little step along the way.
Don't engage in self criticism
for not getting there sooner.
Have kind of pride and self
compassion for yourself along the way.
Those are some easy strategies to do.
So read it to combustion and bridal.
Definitely positive emotions
that all people feel.
And my question is how did you
come up with a specific list?
Because there are a lot more humility.
They respect trust law.
Yeah. So for me, um,
these are the emotions,
and I'm not saying
these are the only ones,
but these are the emotions that underlie
cooperation.
And we owe me ultimately what is
human life about human morality,
about it's about cooperation. Why
do we cooperate? Because we can,
we can do more together than we can alone.
And so these are the emotions that I call
social emotions that exist only within
the context of social interaction.
Um,
I think love works the same way.
I just think love's not as
easy to do because you can't,
it's harder to cultivate love and a
basis for somebody you don't know.
Um, but love is a very powerful emotion
mean. When you think about grit,
what is grit? You know,
people talk about, oh,
the person who worked hard to
get ahead of the CEO. To me,
people who have grit are,
you know,
the mom who works three jobs so
she can support her kid in college.
Or the grandfather who has emphysema,
who's dragging the oxygen tank behind
him to go see his grandchild play on the
soccer field. I mean, to me that's
where grit really comes from.
It's a willingness to sacrifice and I'm
sure we can pivot it to our own success.
And so I think these three emotions are
some of the primary ones. I don't think,
I mean trust, respect, those
things are hugely important.
They're not really emotions.
Um, I think they play into it.
And so I think these are some of the three
strongest that are the most tractable.
But I don't mean to say
that they're the only one.
Yeah.
I think I was decided before anyone.
So you talked about,
uh,
the stress that somebody
incurs controlling their
impulses and kind of, you know,
even the long term health
implications of this. Uh,
I'm thinking of the analogy of something
like strength training where you,
you lift a weight and you know,
over time you get better at,
it becomes easier to do, to exert
the same end goal. I was wondering,
does that analogy not work?
In the case of
the analogy, the analogy works
well in, in, in two ways.
One is you're almost developing kind of a,
uh,
a habit of doing is by
cultivating these traits. Um,
it kind of shapes your way
of looking at the world.
And so suddenly you begin to look for
things to be thankful for or you're
automatically begin to look for links
to other people and have compassion for
them. So they happen more frequently,
but they also have been more intensely.
So there's work not mine, um, that,
uh, where they look at people who,
um, are basically giving
and paying back others.
And what they find is the simple act of,
of, of giving to pay back others, um,
activates the reward center in the brain.
So it actually is something that,
that we perceive as
rewarding to ourselves. Um,
and what we,
what they find is that the more often
you do that for the same type of giving,
the strength of that reward
signal goes up. So it basically,
it's an intrinsic value
to the brain goes up.
And so it strengthens both in
frequency and in intensity.
And then one last thing
I want to say about,
about how we cultivate these within
a work environment like Google or any
corporation,
there's two ways that these emotions flow
in networks I think is very important.
One is like all emotions,
they're catchy. So, um,
there's this thing called
emotional contagion.
So if you're afraid that
we'll kind of rub off on me.
So if my coworker is feeling grateful
that gratefulness will kind of rub off on
the same about their compassion. And so
one, you can catch them from other people,
but the more important way
as they work reciprocally.
So if I'm feeling
compassionate toward you,
it makes me more willing to help you
with something that you're working on for
which you will then feel grateful to me.
And then because you're feeling grateful,
you're more likely than the pay it forward
to somebody else who will then feel
for you. And so you get a network
that's continually reinforcing,
that makes not only the
team collaborate more,
but individual's willingness to,
to work hard themselves goes up and
their stress goes down. Oh, sorry.
I keep skipping you.
Oh yeah,
yeah. Um, I just, uh, wondering
what your thoughts are, uh,
about the dollar experiment.
Um,
and like accounting for
need in that experiment.
You mean the one I had up
here? Yeah. Yeah. So people
always say, well, you know, if,
if valuing the future is so important
than why does anybody value the short
term, right? We shouldn't have even
been extinguished evolutionarily and no.
Uh, sometimes having making a short
term decision makes sense. So, um,
if you need that money to survive,
right?
If that's a lot of money to you because
you come from maybe an economically
disadvantaged background,
um, that can make sense. In
fact, there's work, not mine,
but by lots of people who do
the marshmallow experiment
with kids from different
ses backgrounds.
What they find is kids from
ses backgrounds that are
very disadvantaged where
they don't have a good belief that the
future is going gonna pan out or that the
promises you make about getting money
are actually real or that they can trust
you. They show what is believed
to be less self control, right?
That is, they'll take the smaller
price. I'll take the marshmallow,
but it's not really irrational
in those cases, right?
Because if you believe that the
future is not going to come true,
then take what you've got and run with it.
And the reason we're miscalibrated now
is because we used to live in a world
where there was much less certainty,
right?
I mean you didn't know if there
was going to be food tomorrow.
So if you had a lot of food,
eat it now,
you didn't know if certain things
were going to happen tomorrow.
If you were going to be around tomorrow.
Now in this world,
I know that if I buy a
CD or you know a bond,
it's going to pay me x amount and so many
years I know if I smoke it's going to
be bad for me. I know if I overeat,
it's going to be bad for me.
Certainty is so much higher, but our
brains haven't quite caught up with us.
And that's why we make these irrational
decisions. But to answer your question,
sorry for the long roundabout way is um,
the way that we deal with this in the
research is we make sure when we assigned
people to conditions that we balance out
all of those issues so that within all
of my groups,
before I make one feel grateful and
the other one feel happy and nothing,
we're making sure that ses and need and
although things are balanced so that
they can't be attributable
to those other causes.
But I think you're absolutely right
and that where you're starting from,
what your background expectations are
can greatly determine what seems like a
rational choice for you.
Okay. Thanks. Yeah. Hi. Um,
I was wondering if you had any specific
examples of ways that managers or
leaders have cultivated environments?
Yeah.
Gratitude and compassion that
can ultimately help a team.
Yeah. Or achieve a goal.
Well, it's funny, one of the things
I talk about in the book was a, um,
a study done actually, um, human,
I know it's not called human resources
at Google, I forget what it's called,
but it's basically Google human
resources and they're looking at,
at team success. And, um, you know,
you thought, they thought, well,
what's going to account for team's
success? And they thought, well,
technical expertise,
especially if the manager turned out
that wasn't the biggest predictor,
the biggest predictor was,
was there a culture of,
of empathy on the team that videos
could people trust each other?
Did they feel they could
support each other? Did they,
did the manager instill in the team a
culture where it was okay and expected
that we would talk about problems that
we were having and share with each other?
And to the extent that they
did those teams succeeded.
Why? Well, you know, if, if,
if, if you're working hard to kind
of develop stuff and be creative,
there's always a risk of failure in that.
And so you have to be comfortable
that those around you are going to be
continually to,
to,
to support you and help and help and
rather than try and take advantage of use
and they can climb the
ladder within the work group.
And so I think if you're a manager,
what you can begin to do is
to both emulate it yourself,
but also take time within
the workflow of your,
of your team, whether once a week, once a
day, once a month, whatever it might be,
to engage in these types of exercises
that build empathy and compassion.
Talk about your problems,
talk about your fears,
talk about what's working and what's not.
Another great strategy out there,
Adam Grant often talks about
this is what's called the,
um, circle of reciprocity.
And so what you might do as a,
as a team is,
is you'd put up on the board
everybody's name in your work group,
and then everybody has to write a problem
they're having at work or even not at
work. And then everybody that has
to say, I can help you with this.
You pick one, and you then you
put your name next to that.
And then what you do is you draw
connections from people who've,
here's my problem.
People were willing to help.
And suddenly you see the interconnections.
If everybody does that,
what that then does,
it starts to automatically
instill gratitude and
compassion within the team and
it flows forward. Yup. Hi,
thanks for coming today.
You had a slide that said one 20%,
something about how people with a
certain type of grit tend to fall harder.
Could you elaborate on
that again? Yeah. So, um,
this was a study done where it measured
people's personality trait called
conscientiousness, which is characterized
by being someone who's very detailed,
honored, very focused and always wanting
to do the right thing, suppressing their,
their desires for temptations
so that they can persevere.
And if you look at the
correlation of that and grit,
the correlation is like 0.8 something.
And so if you're high on one,
you're high on the other. Um,
they followed these people, uh,
and when, uh, they experienced a setback,
which I think in this study and one of
the studies was, um, they lost their job.
So it's unemployment. How
much did that affect them? Um,
adjusting for ses and everything else.
The hit to their wellbeing that they
reported in terms of stress and what they
felt and how they dealt with
that was 120% more intense that,
that their, their unease and they're
stressed then were people who were,
who worked and pursue their goals with
a different kind of more inclusive
emotion-based style.
Hi.
That's all you talk about empathy and
compassion and especially in design.
Empathy is such a sexy word.
Um,
but I'm curious about your research
and if you surface any findings on
vulnerability and how does that affect
people's ability to express gratitude,
compassion,
and pride.
So what do you mean by surface? Like
if I, if I show you how I'm vulnerable,
does that make me have more compassionate
others? More compassion toward me?
Um, I guess I'm wondering if
your participants talked about,
um, what does it mean to be vulnerable?
Because I mean, even with like empathy,
you can't truly be empathetic unless you
allow yourself to be vulnerable and not
to possibly experience and trying to
understand the other side. Okay. Oh,
I'm just kinda wondering if there's
any correlation that you found.
So we didn't,
we didn't look at vulnerability per se.
But one thing I want to
point out as these terms,
like empathy and compassion
are often used interchangeably.
They're really different things.
So empathy as you're saying is I'm
allowing myself to understand what you're
doing and to feel what you feel.
So if I have empathy for
you and your distressed,
I'm going to feel that distress.
Um,
compassion is different.
Compassion means, um,
both in the scientific neuroscience
world and in the Buddhist world,
it basically means that I don't
have to feel what you're feeling.
I just have to want to help you.
And what we find is that there is
a big difference. So people who,
who make themselves vulnerable to kind
of allowing myself to feel your anxiety,
your pain, your distress, whatever it may
be, can lead to burnout over time, right?
This is why you hear people talk about
empathy, burnout among caregivers. And so,
um,
our strategy is to help
people feel compassion,
to want to help other people without
having to take on that pain that they're
feeling themselves.
Because it can be paralyzing to do that.
And it's also sometimes, you know,
the, the, the Buddhist will call,
they'll call kind of empathy like that.
They'll call it idiot compassion.
And what I mean by idiot compassion is
the classic example of is it is your
child wants to do something that's like
your child wants to play with a knife
and you say, no, you can't
play with that knife.
And you take it away from the child. The
child starts screaming and crying, right?
Well,
in that moment,
if you wanted to make the kid
feel better and felt compassion,
you'd give him the knife back.
But you know,
that's not good for that
kid's longterm health there.
Same thing if they want to overeat cookies
or they want to go out and play and
not study.
And so sometimes to behave
truly compassionately,
you have to be willing to let the other
person suffer a little bit and help them
through it.
But the way to do that is to not always
take that suffering on yourself in an
empathic way. So you want other people
to know that you understand them,
but engaging in his strategy where you're
feeling what they're feeling can be
very counterproductive.
Does that kind of answer your question?
So then are you referring to pity?
I guess like I kind of did the opposite
of like, empathy is like pity of like,
no,
I think,
I think I think of empathy as your
ability to simulate what somebody else is
feeling and to feel it yourself.
Whereas compassion is wanting them to
feel better and working to help them,
but not feeling their pain.
Hmm. Okay. Thank you. Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you everybody for coming.